the president and GOP establishment
suffered a severe setback in the US
Senate primary runoff in Alabama
yesterday's winner Roy Moore is a
religious right-wing favorite who was
thrown off Alabama Supreme Court twice
more defeated Luther Strange who was
appointed to replace Jeff Sessions
president Trump campaigned for Luther
strange but now he's backing more he
tweeted this morning spoke to Roy Moore
last night for the first time he sounds
like a really great guy who ran a
fantastic race chip Reid is in
Montgomery Alabama with more reaction to
the results chip good morning well good
morning this race is not over yet
Roy Moore will face off against Democrat
Doug Jones in December but of course
Alabama is one of the most conservative
states in the nation so even with his
conservative extreme conservative views
Roy Moore is favored to win last night
Roy Moore said it was God's will that he
beat senator Luthor strange to win the
Republican nomination we can support the
president Tuesday morning more arrived
by horseback to cast his vote and waved
his gun at a campaign rally Monday but
it's his extreme views that really set
him apart crime corruption immorality
abortion sodomy sexual perversion sweep
our land the judge has been removed from
the bench twice once just last year for
rejecting federal orders on same-sex
marriage more even suggested that the
9/11 attacks were a punishment from God
there are consequences when we turn away
from her source for strength while
campaigning for Luther strange president
Trump said he might have made a mistake
but that he would back either candidate
to beat Democrat Doug Jones Roy has a
very good chance of not winning in the
general election I will be backing him
the president spoke with Moore last
night in a phone call and deleted at
least three tweets sent in the last two
days supporting strange I can't explain
why he was willing to take that risk
except that he's a friend and a loyal
friend the race also pitted President
Trump against former White House chief
strategist Steve Bannon who insisted
there's more to come you're gonna see in
state after state after state people
that follow the model of judge more
president Trump said he will come here
to Alabama to campaign for more but he
also suggested that because more is so
controversial it's going to be a tough
race even in this heavily Republican
state charlie chip thanks